on est dans le dernier petit bout qui
existent de la grande plaine horticole
des vertus qui a nourri l'europe donc ce
dernier bout de terrain vous allez
encore le bouffer on à 9300 26 euros
pour vivre un an à 2 si on n'a pas le
jardin qu'est ce qu'on mange
qu'est ce qu'on mange mais on sort de
nos achats mais on est déjà casé on sort
ici c'est ouf eux c'est la liberté
ouf on pense autrement et c'est ce petit
bonheur qu'on a réussi à obtenir
on va le perdre c'est terrible
[Musique]
ce qu'ils veulent c'est faire sortir
tous les gens d'aubervilliers qui sont
pauvres et puis mettre à la place des
gens qui sont qui ont un peu plus
d'argent et ça veut dire gentrification
[Musique]
aubervilliers on à 1,42 mètres carrés
d'espacés verts par habitant on est déjà
dans un des espaces ile de france les
plus denses le plus bétonné et les gens
qui vivent autour leur environnement il
va se dégrader
ils vont perdre en qualité de vie donc
ça c'est honteux c'est ça que font les
jo
l'aménageur il est de mauvaise foi parce
qu'il va compenser les jardiniers c'est
à dire que moi jardinières impactés je
vais retrouver une parcelle mais il ne
compense pas la perte d' espaces verts
il ne comporte pense pas la perte de
zones pas artificielle ise
[Musique]
sur un site de moins d'un hectare
le site du fort d'aubervilliers
représente 36 hectares au global dont 13
hectares de nature donc de jardins des
espaces qu'on appelle tous les espaces
de la couronne bozec les jo de 2024
on était un accélérateur mais c'est
d'abord et avant tout une réponse à un
besoin local
un enfant sur deux aubervilliers sort du
primaire sans savoir sans avoir acquis
les éléments fondamentaux du savoir
nager
[Musique]